>> Brian: THE MIDTERMS ARE
OVER.
OR ARE THEY OVER?
THE LAST TWO SENATE RACES WE
THOUGHT WERE GOING TO THE
G.O.P., I'M TALKING ABOUT
FLORIDA, I'M TALKING ABOUT
ARIZONA.
THOUSANDS OF UNCOUNTED BALLOTS
KEEP POPPING UP, MOSTLY IN THE
DEMOCRATIC LEANING AREAS.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE, AND WHY
ARE THESE ELECTIONS STILL UP IN
THE AIR?
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO HAS HAD IT,
TWEETING "DEMOCRATIC LAWYERS ARE
DESCENDING ON FLORIDA.
THEY'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR THEY
AREN'T JUST THERE TO MAKE SURE
EVERY VOTE IS COUNTED, THEY ARE
HERE TO CHANGE THE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION.
THIS IS WHERE THEY PLAN TO DO
IT."
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO JOINS US
NOW.
WHAT MAKES YOU THINK THAT?
>> THEIR WORDS.
THEY HELD A PRESS CONFERENCE AND
SAID THEY ARE NOT HERE TO HAVE A
RECOUNT, THEY ARE HERE TO WIN.
WE HAVE PROCEDURES IN THE LAW
FOR CLOSE ELECTIONS.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH ANYONE
DOING THAT, HERE IS MY PROBLEM.
THIS IS FOCUSED ON TWO COUNTIES,
AND IN PARTICULAR, ONE COUNTY.
LET ME USE AN EXAMPLE,
BAY COUNTY FLORIDA, WHERE
PANAMA CITY IS, WAS HIT BY A
CATEGORY FOUR HURRICANE ABOUT
TWO WEEKS TO THE DAY OF THIS
ELECTION.
THEY WERE WITHOUT POWER, YOU
GUYS COVERED ALL OF THIS.
THEY DID ALL OF THEIR BALLOTS AT
852% TURNOUT RATE, DESPITE THE
HURRICANE.
THEY DID ALL THEIR BALLOTS,
SUBMITTED THEM ON TIME, THEY
WERE DONE BASICALLY ON ELECTION
NIGHT.
EARLIER THE FOLLOWING MORNING.
BROWARD COUNTY IS STILL
COUNTING, AND THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
CATEGORY FOUR HURRICANE, AND IT
IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THAT THEY
DID THIS.
PROBLEM NUMBER TWO IS WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY VOTES THEY HAVE,
EITHER THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEY WON'T TELL ANYBODY, HOW
MANY BALLOTS ARE LEFT TO COUNT
AND SO FORTH.
IT'S CONCERNING WHEN YOU GO TO
SLEEP AT 3:00 A.M. ON WEDNESDAY
MORNING AFTER THE ELECTION AND
FOR EXAMPLE, RICK SCOTT IS UP BY
50,000 VOTES, WHATEVER IT WAS,
TODAY IS AT 17,000.
THE ONLY COUNTIES THAT ARE STILL
REPORTING OUR PALM BEACH AND
BROWARD COUNTY.
WHO HAVE A HISTORY, BY THE WAY,
OF THESE THINGS.
BROWARD COUNTY LOST TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY A WHILE BACK
BECAUSE THEY WERE OPENING UP
ABSENTEE BALLOTS AND BEGINNING
TO COUNT THEM BEFORE THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO.
IT BROWARD COUNTY IN AUGUST OF
THIS YEAR IN BROWARD COUNTY
MYSTERIOUSLY, OR I SHOULD JUST
SAY, I WON'T USE THAT TERM --
5,000 MALE BALLOTS OCCURRED ON
THE NIGHT OF THE ELECTION.
IT ACTUALLY GREW TO 9,000.
WHEN THEY WERE DONE COUNTING
THOSE, A SCHOOL BOARD RACE THAT
INCLUDES A PARKLAND FATHER,
SUDDENLY THE INCUMBENT WAS ABLE
TO BARELY, BUT SHE DID, AVOID A
RUNOFF.
A JUDGE RACE AT A 400 VOTE
MARGIN AFTER THESE 9,000
VOTES APPEARED.
THIS IS ON A MINIMUM A PATTERN
OF INCOMPETENCE.
VOTERS DESERVE BETTER.
THIS IS NOT EVEN A PARTISAN
THING.
THIS IS A COUNTY THAT APPARENTLY
CANNOT EVEN COUNT VOTES AS WELL
AS A COUNTY THAT JUST GOT WIPED
OUT AS A HURRICANE.
>> Brian: YOU HAVE A SITTING
GOVERNOR UP FOR THE ELECTION.
BRENDA SNIPES ILLEGALLY
DESTROYED BALLOTS IN 2016, SHE
IS STILL IN CHARGE!
NOW THEY CAN'T COUNT THE BALLOTS
IN 30 MINUTES AFTER ELECTION
CLOSES, IT'S STILL NOT DONE.
I JUST TALKED TO
GOVERNOR SCOTT'S OFFICE, HE SAYS
THEY UNDERSTAND THERE HAS GOT TO
BE AN AUTOMATIC RECOUNT, FIRST
BY MACHINE.
IF IT'S STILL CLOSE, THEN BY
HAND.
NOW WE UNDERSTAND THAT ANDREW
GILLUM SAYS, IT LOOKS LIKE HE IS
GOING TO RETRACT HIS RECESSION,
AND HE'S GOING TO LOOK FOR A
RECOUNT THERE AS THE VOTE ARE
BEGINNING TO CLOSE, AS WELL.
SPEAK A RECOUNT IS FINE, THE LAW
PROVIDES FOR THAT APPEARED IN
THE CASE OF A GOVERNORS RACE,
ANDREW GILLUM ARE GOING TO
FEED THE BALLOTS BACK IN THE
MACHINE AND MAKE SURE THE
MACHINE IS ACCURATELY REFLECTING
THEM.
IN THE CASE OF THE SENATE
CAMPAIGN, THEY WILL MANUALLY
RECOUNT THE BALLOTS.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THEY WILL
ONLY MANUALLY RECOUNT UNDER
VOTES AND OVER ABOUT SPIRITS
BALLOTS THAT VOTED FOR MORE THAN
ONE CANDIDATE OR BALLOTS THAT
DID NOT VOTE FOR ANY CANDIDATE,
AND THEY WILL LOOK AT THEM AND
SAY, WAS THERE A MARKING THAT
SHOWED A VOTER'S INTENT?
IT HAS TO BE CONSISTENT
THROUGHOUT THE BALLOTS.
IF YOU PUT A X AND A CIRCLE, YOU
HAVE TO DO IT FOR ALL OF THEM,
NOT JUST ONE RACE.
THAT'S WHEN LAWYERS GET
INVOLVED, FIGHTS BEGINNING TO
HAPPEN, THAT IS WHERE WE'VE SEEN
RACES IN THE PAST -- MY PROBLEM
IS, IF IT'S IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES -- IT'S IN ONE COUNTY,
AND IT HAPPENS TO BE A
DEMOCRATIC COUNTY.
WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> Brian: QUICK, MARK ELIAS IS
COMING IN.
A DEMOCRATIC ATTORNEY, AND GUESS
WHAT, THEY HIRED FUSION GPS.
WE ARE BACK IN THE DOSSIER
CONVERSATION!
MARK ELIAS IS BACK IN OUR LIVES
AS A COUNTRY.
THE CLINTON LAWYERS ARE HERE
THEY ARE GOING TO PUT A LAWSUIT
TOGETHER THAT THE SENATE VOTE,
THE PUNCH FOR THE SENATE WAS WAY
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE BALLOT TO
SEPARATE TO MAKE IT HARD FOR
PEOPLE TO VOTE.
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAL
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAN
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAE
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAT
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAO
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAE
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAA
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAO
THEY WILL SEPARATE          CHAG
WITH THE BALLOTS.
WE MIGHT HAVE ANOTHER MESS IN